welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man we have some
really interesting leaks on Falcon and
the Winter Soldier these have just
dropped on 4chan and subreddit Marvel
Studios spoilers and they bring a hell
of a lot of information with them
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the new leaks and what we
think of them as always take leaks like
this with a grain of salt but if they do
turn out to be true then there will be
heavy spoilers here make sure you click
subscribe to never miss a video and if
you enjoy it then please hit that thumbs
up button without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of Falcon in the Winter
Soldier okay so the leaks are broken up
into several posts with them coming from
both 4chan and subreddit Marvel Studios
spoilers apparently certain members of
the press have had access to rough cuts
of some episodes most notably the pilot
and they detail a lot that goes on in
them according to the leaks the series
opens up right after endgame
there's no Chris Evans cameo however but
clearly his legacy looms large over
everything the series starts with Bucky
sitting alone at the Lakeside bench Sam
approaches him and asks what he's doing
there and is taught from Bucky that he
was thinking about leaving with Steve
ultimately we know he didn't do this but
it shows that Bucky is ready to stop
living in the past
Sam offers Bucky a ride and Bucky asks
if he sure about that given that the two
of them don't have a good track record
with cause he gets in anyway and they
drive for a while down a quiet country
road with the radio blasting at one
point samples over and asks Bucky where
they're going and Bucky answers the
future the show then cues the theme tune
music which is then cut off by Sam
asking okay but do you have a place to
stay dude
Bucky says he doesn't know and sam says
he has an idea we then cut to them
pulling up to the house scene in the
trailer now it turns out that this is
actually Sam's family house and that his
family haven't seen him since the
Accords they asked where he's been and
him and Bucky look at each other and
in unison that's a long story now that's
when we cut to the real title card
that's the introduction and it sounds
really enjoyable I did say I'm a trailer
breakdown video that I thought the house
would be one of old Steve Rogers but a
love comment said that they thought it
would be Sam's this is because of the
New Orlean setting which is tied in with
Anthony Mackey's backstory so it does
seem to line up a lot with that and it
adds a ton of weight to it now not only
does this show us some of Sam's past but
it also gives him a place that people
will be able to find him at Sam begins
training and then general Ross shows up
it turns out that Sam could be pardoned
for his a chords violation and he'll be
allowed to keep the shield and the
mantle but only if he undergoes the
serum procedure Sam is reluctant and
says that he needs to think about it but
he immediately weary of this agreement
encourages Sam to refuse saying the
shield isn't worth out living the people
you love this leads into Isaiah's
introduction and he calls Sam on a
burner phone and they meet Isaiah shows
Sam photos from the serum experiments
that were conducted following Steve's
death many of which killed test subjects
and we learn that Steve was the only
survivor
following his ire and Sam's meeting Sam
declines the serum and turns the shield
in which is given to us agent as he
undergoes the serum procedure it's
revealed the serum allows the recipients
mind to be controlled
Sam trusts us aging to take up the
mantle however John Walker is unaware
that he's part of a bigger plan u.s.
agent fights a lot like Captain America
however he's much more brutal and he
hits a lot harder with the shield they
apparently do an update to the
star-spangled man with a plan and even
have a rap verse on it which I must
admit I'm a bit excited for just to say
how bad it's gonna be anyway Sam and
Bucky's Starr their own missions for the
government to repair their reputation
they're led by agent 13 now some people
want Bucky to serve life in prison and
he's haunted by his past publicly he's
charming and witty but when he's alone
he struggles with his inner demons and
doesn't want to be used as a weapon
again the only person he trusts to lead
him is agent 13 and he says that out of
everyone is she's the most like Steve
Falcon and Winter Soldier call
themselves the
blip brothers Sam also begins Falcon air
force training now we did see this in
the trailer as well and I'm not sure if
this is a scene later in the show or if
it's just part of the training the
soldiers did look like Hydra agents due
to their colors however it could all
just be a simulation as there's no
mention of Hydra in any of the leaks
Falcon and winter soldier tracked down C
MO and managed to take him hostage
during this Bucky comes face to face
with him and Zemo tries to trigger him
using the words however instead of going
off
Bucky just empties the gun in front of
him they managed to capture him and it
turns out that they're doing this in
order to take information from him about
a crime syndicate called the alchemists
these could be the big main villains and
it is possible that this is who Falcon
was fighting in the skies now else we
learn that the trigger words were on the
whole deactivated the final trigger word
was not the lika says that many of the
people who heard about the leaks online
were pretty upset by the prospect of
sharees work being reckoned they just
wanted to clarify it absolutely won't be
the final trigger as many of you may
have guessed his Sputnik which was never
used as it was a worse case fail-safe
for this reason and Bucky never
remembered the cold nor was it in the
cold word book naturally sure he didn't
get rid of something she didn't know was
there
Zemo discovers this trigger word and
it's actually a deactivation code that
shuts the character down mentally
Simo uses it to knock Bucky out
instantly and though he's just
unconscious a lot of people including
Sam think that he's dead Zemo escapes
and then starts to play a more
villainous role in the show in the wake
of this sam goes and gets the shield
back and he's once more confronted by
general Ross now we don't have anything
about us agents stopping from being
Captain America but obviously from the
comics who know that it becomes US agent
so it is safe to assume that he does end
up passing over the mantle anyway that's
all of the leaks that we have so far on
this show that seemed legitimate before
we get into the rest of the video I just
wanna let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the Infinity Saga box set
to one random subscriber all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts and the updates
in the comment section below
but when it's gonna be chosen at random
on the 15th of March in the settle be
shipped out from then whoever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
he takes part now as for my thoughts on
the leak so far I'm very excited for the
show after hearing these they all sound
like natural evolutions from the way
things that were left at the end of
endgame and I absolutely love the
building blocks that are set up here a
big problem that people have had is that
Sam is doing a lot of this without the
Super Soldier Serum and I'm glad that
they at least acknowledge why doesn't
want to take it Sam is someone that has
always just been a normal guy and I
think it adds a lot more stakes to the
show knowing that he basically has to
fight tooth and nail throughout it there
is a chance that he could actually die
so this adds a lot more ramifications
there's also rumors that a mega red will
be popping up in the show at some point
the character is synonymous with the
x-men so it's possible that they could
be finally introducing mutants into the
MCU from what I've heard about the leaks
on other films and projects such as one
division and Black Widow characters from
the x-men are slowly going to start
popping up from time to time in the
series and these will slowly build up to
the introduction of the main team after
being dropped in different things
overall though I have to say I'm very
happy with how things are shaping up the
three Disney Plus shows that we saw
teased at the Super Bowl all have
aspects of them I find highly
interesting and tonally they all seem to
be pulling from different genres this
definitely feels more like a spiked
gorilla that is in line with the Winter
Soldier movie and it's one of my
favorites in the MCU I'm very hype to
see if it carries over that tone of that
year Civil War is a film that has
massive ramifications here - and that
was a big movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that I'm excited to see have
characters pop back up so yeah very very
hyped and hopefully these turned out to
be true because I think the show will be
great if they do either way we will find
out in August when the series releases
on Disney Plus worldwide
that's right UK we're finally getting it
at the same time as everyone else yeah
in the meantime though I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the plot leaks and if
you're excited for the show comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please hit the like
button and make sure you check out our
full breakdown of some of the insane
details we noticed in Avengers infinity
war after binge watching the MCU it's
one of our best videos so definitely
check it
after this you want to support the
channel from his letters 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you access the content early and
can also suggest video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get made you wanna come chat
us after the show either follow us at
Definition YT click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you